[Musique]
bon écoute et si la manière dont je suis
habillé si ce que je tient dans la main
et si ma façon de parler ne suffisent
pas vous alerter sur le genre de choses
que vous allez voir
alors je ne fais pas ce qu'il fera ce
que je sais c'est qu'il ne vous reste
plus que trois secondes avant d'en
découvrir bien plus 2 on vous aura
prévenu sort du chan moi aussi je
travaille ici
bienvenue dans mon bureau
tu m'as dit que tu étais opératrice
téléphoniques aux urgences
oui c'était beaucoup ja souviens
absolument tous les fantasmes et ses
besoin de quelqu'un pour m'aider à
nettoyer et être mon body guard serait
kevin costner et moi où tu n'existes
kevin costner se prend une balle à la
fin tu me fais confiance
combien tu payes
[Musique]
par mois un peu ta copine à dominatrice
il ya longtemps on était en quelque
sorte amoureux une amitié amoureuse
quelque chose d'assez fusionner c'est
compliqué ça le monde croit qu'être
dominatrice et que sexuel la fac
n'attend pas les dominatrices alors
qu'en fait cette libère de l'inde
dites moi ce qui vous a mais en fait je
viens pas vraiment pour moi c'est pour
vous excusez moi je n'ai pas très bien
désolé c'est plus pour moi c'est pour
mon mari
je suis pas fait pour ce qui vient de se
passer des plus courageux que ce que tu
crois
ce que tu fais avec moi c'est super quoi
pourquoi tu me racontes jamais rien
parce que si je te disais ce que nous
allons faire avant de le faire tu ne le
ferai jamais salut je retourne au rami
ça open bar à 10,6 standford moorhouse
spelman à
[Musique]
quelque chose qu'einstein a passé toute
sa vie à essayer de faire tu
on a prouvé que faire un voyage dans le
passé c'était possible il faut seulement
travailler dessus encore quelques temps
ça me fout la trouille mais tu
m'inspires toi tu vas aller loin c'est
sûr et comme papa est plus là c'est à
moi tu aider à y arriver si tu as besoin
que tu joues au grand frère tout le
temps eh ben je suis le seul grand frère
que tu es
[Applaudissements]
police de new york ne bougeait plus
[Musique]
calvin walker un adolescent noir de 19
ans aurait été tué par balle par un
agent de la police de new york
walker avait pour seul et unique arme
son téléphone cellulaire
je suis tellement désolé de tout ce qui
est arrivé je pouvais remonter le temps
je rangerai tout ça on retourne dans le
passé on le sort de là il est sauvé
l'inra qu'un nombre limité de fois pour
le faire donc il faut que tout soit
absolument parfait quel jour on est
aujourd'hui on est le 28 juin
[Musique]
sebastian il faut que ça marche il
s'agit de contrôler un truc sur lequel
on n'a aucun contrôle
mon frère méritait pas ce qui lui est
arrivé il manque combien de fois tu es
allé dans le passé si on n'est pas des
super héros
où est passée la justice on peut pas
refaire ça nous reste seulement deux
sauts dans le passé
où est la justice pour nos fils pour nos
filles
corps tout ça va-t-il s'arrêter dans
tout notre pays il faut que tu nous
écoutes tu vas te faire des centres avec
toi par terre alors est ce que ma mère
est là il ya plus que nous toi et nous
avec qui tu étais au parc tonnelle pas
son nom c'est juste que je me suis perdu
où as tu vu la jeune femme de qui vous
parlez
la joggeuse haut et de coups et violée
chaque jeune noir qui étaient dans le
parc la nuit dernière est suspect je
veux chacun de ces gamins
qu'est ce qui se passe avec mon fils
votre fils est impliqué dans un violent
à central park
non non c est mignon c'est un possédé
une seconde à perdre et ils t'ont vu
violé cette femme
j'ai pas vu de femmes ni battue qui que
ce soit chez lui aucune kevin ce vieux
aucune femme
tout de suite je veux voir mon fils
[Musique]
quoiqu'il puisse dire j'ai rien fait je
sais
ne parviennent pas à recouper avec les
éléments principaux du crime tout ce
qu'il nous faut c'est qu'un seul des
discours coïncide avec les faits ces
vidéos ne sont pas aussi reprochable que
la police voudrait nous faire croire
nous dénonçons cette injustice il n'y a
pas la moindre président ces adolescents
qui lui tjrs et vêtements innocent il
n'a pas commis ces crimes sont coupables
j'aime les gens
ils ont pas arrêté de nous mentir
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'il fasse
d'autre j'ai fait des intérêts
c'est jeanne pas d'entendre sipa
il se rapproche de moi ils sont de plus
en plus proche
c'est moi qui vais être amené à la
maison
ils ont dit que si je joue un jeu je
pourrais rentrer chez moi et c'est tout
ce que je voulais la police est prête à
tout faire
partir ou foot entre ils vont me tuer
c'est ma vie
je pense qu'on devrait pas plaider
coupable pour un truc qu'on n'a pas fait
ok donc on va se battre
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ess margherita et pompidou tiers temps
avant j'attends ça veut dire bien sûr je
sais très bien ce que ça veut dire pas
blake sort n'a jamais reconnu gracias
peg perego tout je veux pas vivre dans
une caravane doute mais un jour tu
regretteras notre vie de bohème crois
pas non si sa tante fait un concert
classique avec un orchestre de jeunes au
début des vacances thuram en c ou en
italie à venise l'argent moi je ne
trouve pas sous le sabot d'un cheval à
france je sais mais j'aimerais trop y
aller j'aime bien meilleure idée
on va y aller tous ensemble à venise
c'est ce qu'a bien avec notre caravane
pas ça ne fait pas plaisir
tous les chemins mènent à rome et venise
[Musique]
bienvenue chez les dingues juste en face
de venise et un camping pas cher du tout
on n'est pas bien ici incline à côté
l'usiné le cul mais le fait pas de bruit
je te positive à l'amour il n'y a qu'une
règle de l'audace encore de l'audace
toujours de l'audace monfils
mais content de nous on te convient pas
comme parents oui j'ai honte j'ai honte
qu'on soit pas une famille normale mais
ça n'existe pas les gens normaux et mais
cette grande nouvelle à t'annoncer est
avorté pillages
tu sais comment je les baptisés huîtres
huîtres ça lâche pas une vitre et le
papillon pavillon salage assez sagement
au coucher ça fait longtemps que vous
êtes incarcéré tout ça vous avez
l'impression de ne rien contrôler ici
c'est normal je peux très bien le
comprendre
[Musique]
j'ai besoin que tu signe ça
rappeler ici que ça vous plaise ou non
vous allez réintégrer la détention
général
padoue avec les autres est ce que tout
le monde est prêt à traquer ouvre la
porte
[Musique]
si tu arrives à rester là tant plus de
cinq secondes tu te prends avec moi
but du programme c'est d'apprendre à
dresser les chevaux sauvages
et au bout du compte notre
réhabilitation
notre objectif est de ressentir de
l'empathie c'était moi l'acoss tu me
laisser tout seul
tu crois que monter à cheval ça va
changer les choses tubercule est en
forme
on peut les dépôts et les autres il n'y
a rien à en tirer
[Musique]